tout le monde convient qu'il faut
changer la façon dont les choses
fonctionnent l'été dernier Christian
Dubé présentait santé Québec un projet
d'agence pour gérer les opérations
quotidiennes dans le réseau de la santé
il y aura pas de brassage de structure
sur le terrain qui vont venir tout
chambouler mais dans un projet de loi
qui le déposera cette semaine le
ministre de la Santé ira bien plus loin
au niveau salarial par exemple il
aimerait pouvoir payer différemment deux
professionnels qui exercent le même
métier si l'un d'eux travaille dans des
conditions plus difficiles par exemple
on a des crèmes
les syndicats s'inquiète aussi que le
ministre veuille rendre l'ancienneté des
employés valides dans toute la province
plutôt que dans un seul établissement
une mesure qui pourrait créer un exode
des régions et affaiblir le sentiment
d'appartenance du personnel selon cette
représentante syndicale s'il y a quelque
chose qu'on peut pas se payer comme
système de santé c'est de
d'amoindrir ce sentiment d'appartenance
là parce qu'il restera plus grand chose
pour inciter les gens à travailler en
santé ce réseau-là il est il est déjà
très très
fragile c'est pas le temps justement de
mettre le feu au pot dans le corps une
fois avec une nouvelle nouvelle
structure de nouvelles structure puis de
nouvelles confrontations Christian Dubé
veut aussi serrer la vis au médecin
spécialiste dans les forçants à
travailler dans des régions moins bien
desservies ou accepter des horaires plus
difficiles une mesure nécessaire selon
cette ex dirigeant du réseau écoute on
arrive quelqu'un
urgence se nomme des praticiens
regardent le patient et dit en t'as
besoin consultation
spécialiste pas ici avant 8 heures
demain matin
il passe toute la nuit sur une civière
qu'on garde le patient elle pour rien la
Fédération des médecins spécialistes n'a
pas voulu commenter mais si le ministre
touche à leur autonomie professionnelle
plusieurs attendent à une levée de
bouclier
le réseau mais ils veulent pas se faire
imposer aussi des tâches qui parfois
vont être impossible à faire Christian
Dubé répète qu'il veut améliorer
l'efficacité du réseau mais un autre de
ses chevaux de bataille concerne
l'imputabilité qu'il veut rehausser en
ajoutant un patron dans chaque lieu où
on donne des soins ou des services en
santé dans la province ici alexandre
Duval Radio-Canada Québec